the next gentleman is singularly
distinguished not only did he walk away
with the award for the best performance
by an actor last year for his fine work
in a double life but he also holds the
distinction of being one of Hollywood's
most illustrious citizens and in the
bargain a neighbor of Jack Benny mr.
Ronald Colman
now ladies and gentlemen that this is
very different for me from last year
this year I know how I got to the stage
last year I heard my name and the next
thing I remember was having the award
put in my hands complete unconsciousness
between it seems sad that I'm about to
deliver as serious a shock to one of
these ladies but I've no doubt she will
survive never in my memory of the
Academy as the competition for an award
being so tense and exciting these were
five great performances and the Oscar
which rewards the winner should shine
with a special luster and the other
contestants find a real pride in the
race they have run the nominees are
Ingrid Bergman
Joan of Arc Sarah Pictures RKO radio
Olivia de Havilland in the snake pit
20th Century Fox Irene Dunne in I
remember mama RKO radio Barbara Stanwyck
in sorry wrong number
Hal B Wallis productions paramount and
Jane Wyman in Johnny Belinda Warner
Brothers and the winner Jane Wyman
I accept this very gratefully for
keeping my mouth shut once I think I'll
do it again